الغى الكنيسه الاسرائيلي بنودا قانوني
استمر 18 عاما كانت تحضر على المستوطنين
دخول اربع مستوطنات بالضفه الغربيه وتاتي
هذه الخطوه غداه تصريحات لوزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي ادنى بها في باريس امام خارطه
لاسرائيل تضم الاردن والاراضي الفلسطينيه
انكر فيها وجود شعب فلسطيني ودع البيت
الابيض الى اخذ ذلك بعين الاعتبار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات في اي سياق يمكن ان
نقرا اصرار حكومه اليمين المتطرف في
اسرائيل على التصعيد ضد الفلسطينيين وما
الرساله التي يبعثها تصعيدها الاخير ضد
الاردن ثم ما هي الاعتبارات الداخليه
والخارجيه التي تحدد سياسات حكومه نتنياهو
ونهجها في التعامل مع الفلسطينيين ودول
المنطقه ثم كيف ستنعكس سياسه هذه الحكومه
على استقرار شرق الاوسط وعلى تاكيدات
واشنطن المتكرره بشان الحرص على التهدئه
والحيلوله دون تفجر الاوضاع بالمنطقه
[موسيقى]
في سياق تصعيد اسرائيلي تعددت مظاهره
وبموازاه استمرار حملات الاغتيالات والدعم
والاعتقال ضد الفلسطينيين الغى قانون كانت
تجرم الاستيطان في اربع مستوطنات شمال
الضفه الغربيه على مدى الاعوار الثمانيه
عشر الاخيره الخطوه التي كانت جزءا من
شروط احزاب اليمين المتطرف نظيرا انضمامها
الى حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو والغت باثر
فوري بنودا قانونيه كانت تحضر على
المستوطنين الدخول نطاق اربع مستوطنات تم
اخلائها في الضفه الغربيه عام 2005 وهي
جانيم وكاديم وحومش وسنور بما يعني
امكانيه عوده المستوطنين الى هذه المواقع
من جديد
التصعيد الاسرائيلي تجاوز الفلسطينيين
ليشمل الاردن التي كانت خريطتها الى جانب
اراضي الضفه الغربيه جزءا من خريطه وقف
امامها وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي باسرائيل
لينكر وجود الشعب الفلسطيني من الاساس حيث
الذي يتزعم تحالف الصهيونيه الدينيه
العنصري في كلمه القاها الاثنين امام
مؤتمر خاص للصندوق القومي اليهودي في
باريس ان الشعب الفلسطيني اختراع عمره اقل
من 100 عام وانه لا يوجد شيء اسمه الشعب
الفلسطيني وان على الاليزي والبيت الابيض
الاصغاء الى هذه الحقيقه على حد تعبيره
[موسيقى]
نبدا مناقشه هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من تل
ابيب الدكتور مردخاي كدار استاذ العلوم
السياسيه بجامعه بارلان والباحث في شؤون
الشرق الاوسط دكتور مردخاي
تصريحات الوزير وزير الماليه الاسرائيليه
هل تقصه ام تخص الحكومه
الحقيقه هل هناك ذكر الاصابه الفلسطيني
قبل اكثر من 100 عام في اي كتاب واي منشور
لا بالمره واعلى فكره هؤلاء المسمن
بالفلسطينيون هم عندهم الناس اسمهم المصري
ومسارها
والفيومي والحوراني
دكتور مرتفعي لو كنا لو كنا في محاضره
للتاريخ لا انصت اليك بشكل اكثر ولكن
سؤالي واضح تصريحات الوزير هل تعنيه كارثه
زعيم لتحالف الصهيونيه ام تعني الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
سؤال سياسي
طيب اعيد ايضا مره اخرى صياغه سؤالي سؤالي
ليس مجال التاريخ لو كان في التاريخ
لاعدادنا هذه الحلقه وقلنا انها للتاريخ
سؤالي سياسي تصريحات الوزير هل تعني
الحكومه نعم ام لا
جوابي وانا تصريحات الوزير تعني الحقيقه
وليست موقف سياسي هذا ليس
السياسي هذا حقيقه تاريخيه لا يمكن لاحد
ينكرها حتى ولو جاء على شاشه الجزيره اذا
ليس هناك شيء اسمه الفلسطينيون ولا دوله
اسمها الاردن
هل يمكن يمكنك ان تاتي باسم الملك
الفلسطيني قبل اكثر من 100 عام او رئيس
فلسطيني او العمله الفلسطينيه او العاصمه
الفلسطينيه هذا كل شيء وليد القرن العشرين
ما بعد تاسيس حركه
المقاومه هناك الفلسطينيه في عام 60 طيب
انت تجيبني في التاريخ وانا اسالك في
السياسه اذا ليس هناك بالنسبه للوزير
والحكومه الاسرائيليه شيء اسمه الاردن
بالاضافه ليس هناك شيء اسمه شعب الفلسطيني
مملكه محترمه لنا يعني
ليس لنا في الاردن هل انت تنتقي من كلام
الوزير ما تختار الوزير قال ليس هناك شعب
فلسطيني ووضع خارطه لاسرائيل من ضمنها
الاردن اي ينفي وجود ايضا دورها اسمها
الاردن هل تختار من كلام الوزير ما تريد
الخريطه الموجوده في كل بيت هنا في
اسرائيل هذه الخارطه على يميني وهي فيها
ارض اسرائيل نهار والبحر ليس لنا اي ناقه
ولا جمل في الاردن والاردن يعني مملكه
محترمه لنا لا معها على قد سلام وتعاوننا
الكثير من المجالات
ليس لنا اي شيء في مملكه الاردن وانا لا
اعلم
معنى ذلك دكتور مردخاي ان هذا الكلام
الهوما ذكرت بانه خريطه في كل بيت
اسرائيلي وما يثار الان في ظل سيطره
الاحزاب الدينيه المتطرفه ان هذا هو ناهج
الحكومه في السنوات القادمه لا وجود
للفلسطينيين ولا وجود لدوله اسمها الاردن
او حتى اذا تكلمنا على هذه الخارطه
المزعومه بين النهر الى البحر
خريطه على الارض لا يمكن انكارها هل قطر
موجوده على الخارطه نعم اسرائيل ايضا
موجوده للخريطه مثل قطر لا اكثر ولا اقل
ولذلك هذا هي ارض اسرائيل التي وعدها عصبه
الامم يعني هي المناظمه الامميه التي كانت
قبل الحرب العالميه
من جهه تقول الاردن دوله محترمه والان
تنفي كل هذا الامتداد من النهر الى البحر
لم افهمك
من يمكن هذا
هل الاردن دوله محترمه ام انها دوله غير
موجوده
الاردن تمتد من نهر الاردن الى الشرق وليس
لنا اي شبر في هذه المنطقه من شرق الاردن
غاب الاردن هذا عهد اسرائيل للموعوده وين
المشكله ان تتلاعب بالكلمات دكتور مردخاي
سؤالي واضح ارجو ان يكون جوابك واضحا قلت
دوله اسرائيل من النهر الى البحر وهي
خريطه معلقه في كل بيت اسرائيلي ثم قلت
الاردن دوله محترمه اجبني بشكل واضح حتى
افهمك
المملكه الهاشميه الاردنيه موجوده ان لم
تعلم موجوده الى الشرق من نهر الاردن
اسرائيل موجوده الى الغرب منها للردون اين
انا الالتباس الالتباس ان الوزير وزير
الماليه مديريه علق خريطه ليس من ضمنها
دوله اسمها الاردن واسمها اسرائيل لغاها
من الخارطه
اذا تلك الخارطه التي
شاهدناها في ذلك المظهر هي الخارطه التي
اتت بها نسبه الامم للشعب اليهودي كامله
ان تخلق المملكه الامارات
بعض الاردن كانت بدات كامامه نحن نتكلم عن
تصريح يصدر من وزير وليس من شخصيه عاديه
او رجل حتى زعيم لحزب نتكلم عن وزير من
ضمن حكومه لديه مسؤولون اسالك كيف ترى
ردود الفعل الدولي حتى الان المستنكره
والمستهجنه لتصريحات الوزير وزير الماليه
وصفتها بالعنصريه وحتى استهجنتها
ليس هناك اي استهجان اليوم الوضع على
الارض وعلى الخارطه كمان هي ان هناك الى
الشرق منار الاردن هناك مملكه هاشميه
اردنيه ولا جلل احترام الى الغرب من
الاردن
اسرائيل هذا هو ليس هناك استهجال او لم
تستمع الى رد فعل على سبيل المثال الجانب
الفرنسي حيث القى الوزير كلمته هناك
استهجال واستنكار واستخفاف بما جعل لسان
الوزير
الدوله الفرنسيه
هذه مع الاردن لليهود ولكن اربع سنين بعد
ذلك كان نسبه الامم قرار اخر
وانشات الاماره الاردنيه التي تحولت الى
المملكه في الخمسينيات وعلى الوزير
الفرنسي ان يراجع مصادره وتاريخ التصويت
الفرنسي على الخطط الامميه في تلك الايام
شكرا لك من تل ابيب الدكتور مرتخاي كدار
العلوم السياسيه بجامعه والباحث في شؤون
الشرق الاوسط
الان استقبل ضيفي من
من عمان
وهو سمير حباشنه وزير الداخليه والثقافه
الاردني
تابعت تصريحات الوزير وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي كيف وجدتها طبعا الجانب
الاردني رد على ما جاء لسان الوزير وابلغ
به السفير الاسرائيلي لدى عمار وكان
الموقف الاردني واضحا لكن في تحديد
المسؤوليه برايك هل هو كلام لزعيم تحالف
ام هو كلام تتحمل مسؤوليته الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
سيادهم مساء
استمعت
الرجل التلفيقي هذا اللي بيمفي وجود الشعب
الفلسطيني وهذا كلام طبعا لا يرد عليه
لانه الشعب الفلسطيني على الارض هو شعب
موجود واليوم الفلسطينيين العرب اكثر من
الاسرائيليين اليهود في فلسطين التاريخيه
على اي حال انا افهم ذهب اليه
الوزير الاسرائيلي بانه في سياق التحول
السريع والمتنامي لدوله اسرائيل الى نحو
الى الى الداعشيه اليهوديه اذا جاز
التعبير هذه دوله اليوم بتطرح المشروع
الصهيوني بلا اي رتوش ولا اي مكياج هذا هو
المشروع الصهيوني في بداياته ان فلسطين
اليوم والاردن اليوم هي جزء لا يتجزا من
المشروع الصهيوني
والخريطه اللي رسمها انا بتقديري
بشكل من اشكال اعلان الحرب انا اتذكر او
قرات عند قبل ان تغزو المانيا بولندا اضم
بولندا الى خارطه المانيا وهذا هو حقيقه
المشروع الصهيوني المشروع الصهيوني الذي
يعتقد ببداياته ان الاردن جزء لا يتجزا من
المشروع الصهيوني الكبير اليوم احنا امام
حكومه
داعشيه بكل ما تعني الكلمه مثل ما تفضلت
اليوم في تقرير الجزيره اربع
مستوطنات رجعوا عنها اليوم يناقشوا في في
الكنيست مشروع وذكرته الجزيره اليوم في
احد النشرات يتحدث عن قانون لمنع الحديث
بالعقيده المسيحيه في في دوله الاحتلال
بيطلع قرار المستوطنات بعد شرم الشيخ
تماما
حتى بعد رد الحكومه حتى بعد رد الحكومه
وما قدمته من توضيح
يا سيدي هذا التوضيح على استحياء مثل حديث
اللي قبل شوي حكى من من فلسطين المحتله
الكلام التلفيقي هذا اليوم الموقف غير
واضح اطلاقا انا اعتقد اننا في الاردن يجب
ان ناخذ ما يجري من تنامي للقوى المتطرفه
والداعشيه في فلسطين
المحتله على محمل الجد انا ادعو شخصيا الى
اعاده فوريه لخدمه العلم في المملكه
الاردنيه الهاشميه ادعو الشعب الاردني بكل
اطيافه بواديه في مخيماته في مدنه في
اريافه ان يخزن السلاح وان يخزن الذخيره
لانني اعتقد ان هذه الحكومه التي تضم
اليوم 40% من المتطرفين امام تنامي التطرف
في المجتمع الاسرائيلي اعتقد الحكومه
القادمه سوف تكون حكومه اغلبيه وانا اعتقد
بنفس الدرجه لمهدده فيها مشروع الدوله
الفلسطينيه
من الخليل السيد عادل شديد وهو الباحث
المختص في الشان السيد عادل ايضا كيف تبعت
هذه التصريحات من قبل الوزير محاوله فهم
ما جاء لسانه بخصوص الفلسطينيين لا وجود
للفلسطينيين وهذه الخريطه التي كانت خلفه
تزيح دوله باكملها الاردن باكمله وتضمه
الى دوله اسرائيل كيف فهمت هذا التطور
مساء الخير لك استاذ عبد القادر
ولجمهورك يعني قبل شهور قليله من على قناه
الجزيره تحدثت انا وكان ضيفكم من عمان
الاستاذ طاهر المصري حين قلت انه الاصوات
او التيارات
اليمينيه في الخريطه السياسيه الحاليه في
اسرائيل
باتت تشكل اكثريه من الذين يطالبون
باعاده ضم الضفه الشرقيه الاردن لما يسمى
دوله اسرائيل وبالمناسبه يعني انا استغرب
هذه المفاجاه وردود الفعل حول الخريطه
التي ظهرت بالامس في باريس اثناء محاضره
الوزير
على اليمين بس
موضوع ان تكون الضفه شرطيه او الاردن جزء
من خريطه اسرائيل
ليس بالموضوع الحديث هذا
بيان الحكومه الاسرائيليه
اليوم الخجول لا اعتقد انه احد بالاردن او
بالمنطقه يجهل انه مقر حزب الكود في تل
ابيب بزعامه نتنياهو على باب وهذا الشعار
شعار الضفتين خريطه اسرائيل العراق من
الشرق وشوريا ولبنان حتى اجزاء من العراق
ومن سوريا ومن لبنان يفترض ان تكون جزء من
من الخريطه النهائيه لدوله
الاحتلال
هذا الكلام دائما موجود في الادبيات خاصه
لدى التيارات الدينيه والمتطرفه
الاسرائيليه بشكل عام ان يظهر هذه المره
على اللسان وزيره بهذه الطريقه وفي ظل
التركيبه الحكوميه الحاليه الوضع في داخل
اسرائيل ما الذي يعنيه هذا البعد او هذا
المستجد
يعني اعتقد انه حديثنا لم يكن عفوي ولم
تكن زله لسان ولم يكن يعبر فقط عن عن رايه
بالمناسبه بدايه ان تكون الاردن جزء من
المشروع الصهيوني وجزء من دوله اسرائيل لم
يكن من التيارات الدينيه كان من التيار
العلماني القومي جماعه ابو تنس في حدود
الليكود اليوم
جابوتنسكي ونتنياهو الاب من حم بيجن حتى
يهود اولمرد رئيس الحكومه الاسبق اللي بعض
العرب الفلسطينيين يتعاطى معه وكانه حمامه
سلام لازال يؤمن بان الاردن يجب ان تكون
جزء من دوله اسرائيل
رئيس دوله اسرائيل السابق
من اشد الداعمين لكي تكون الاردن جزء من
دوله اسرائيل بالمناسبه قبل شهور غرد ابن
بنيامين نتنياهو ابن الحكومه ابن زعيم حزب
الكود على تويتر وعلى الفيسبوك قال اذا
كان جدي عن نتنياهو الاب قد قبل ان تتخلى
اسرائيل في بدايه مشروع عن الاردن انا
الاوان ليقوم والدي بين قوسين بنيامين
نتنياهو وان يعيد الاردن الى خريطه
اسرائيل وعن يضمها الى اسرائيل بمعنى
اليوم بس
مهمه جدا السيد عادل هذا الوزير سمير
الحبشنه عن الحسابات الاردنيه الان حتى
عندما توضح الحكومه الاسرائيليه وتحاول ان
تاخذ مسافه من تصريحات الوزير هل هذا كافي
لطمانه الجانب الاردني
ابدا انا لا اعتقد حتى انه في رد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه كان هناك اي تطمين بالعكس هو
شيء مواربه شيء محاوله للمرور عن هذه
المساله دون ان يحددوا موقف واضح جدا من
الدوله الاردنيه واستقلاليه الدوله
الاردنيه واعتراف في معاهده السلام انا
اعتقد مثل ما تفضل الضيف من الخليل
المحترم انا اعظم شعارهم الاول حتى
العلمانيين مثل ما قال ان لنهر الاردن ضفه
واحده لنا والاخرى لنا المشروع الاسرائيلي
الصهيوني يسير ضمن محطات ومن ضمن مراحل
واعتقد انهم يتحذروا الى مرحله جديده
الاردن ليس ببعيد عنها لكن انا بدي اقول
للاسرائيليين لعتاه التطرف وللمعتدلين
فيهم احنا اليوم بذكرى معركه الكرامه
ويعود لتصريحات وزير الحرب انذاك مش وماذا
قال عن الاردنيين وماذا قال عن
الفلسطينيين وماذا قال عن الجيش الاردني
في معركه الكرامه ليعوا ان هذه ليست لقمه
سائغه هذه بلاد لها اهل ولها اهل يدافع
عنها بالدم وبالروح وانا بعيد وبكرر على
الدوله الاردنيه ان لا تكتفي بتصريح
الرد الاسرائيلي على ما قال الوزير
المتطرف وان عده كاردنيين كدوله وكشعب
لاسوى الاحتمالات طيب التحذر الى المرحله
القادمه
لا نريد ان نفزع
اعذرني على المقاطعه فقط اسال ضيفي من
الخليل سيد عادل الشديد هذه الحكومه منذ
ان نصبت تقتيل يومي في الفلسطينيين لا
تكتفي بالتصريحات هذا الوزير تحديدا تكلم
عن مسح حواره من على وجه الارض قال لا
وجود للفلسطينيين وضع خارطه تضم بلدا
باكمله الى دوله مزعومه وقوانين تتيح
للاسرائيليين العوده الى مستوطنات والغاء
قانون كان يحضر على الاسرائيليين العوده
الى هذه المستوطنات ما الذي يجري فيما
يتعلق بما تهدف له هذه الحكومه بشكل اساسي
يعني اعتقد انه حديث اسمه بالامس في باريس
فيما يتعلق بانه لم يكن هنالك شعر فلسطيني
بالتاريخ وان الشعب الفلسطيني بدعه قبل
100 عام لافشال المشروع الصهيوني وانه لم
يكن هنالك ملكا للفلسطينيين في يوم من
الايام وان يتحدث من امام خريطه اسرائيل
بما فيها الاردن هذا اعلان برنامج سياسي
جديد يمثل ويعكس قناعه اكثر من ثلثي
المجتمع اليهودي اليوم الديني والعلماني
بمعنى انه الحديث شكرا للدولتين يجب ان
ينتهي وهو كان واضحا عندما
البيض من الخليل عادل شديد الباحث المختص
في الشان الاسرائيلي وكذلك الشكر لديه في
ابن عمان سمير الحبشنه وزير الداخليه
والثقافه الاردنيه السابق شكرا جزيلا لكما
ختام هذه الحلقه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]